will monday mark the beginning of the
recovery
covent gardens gearing up for when
restaurants can serve outside
and non-essential shops reopen do you
worry that the world has gone online
and it will never get back to what it
was not at all covent garden's been
around for 500 years we're very
confident it'll be around for a very
long time
i think both of those things can
co-exist and every time we've had a
lockdown and we've had an easing of
lockdown
what we've seen is restaurants full
shops full
cues to get in people wanting to come
out connect with each other at a very
very human level
but also experience the best of london
for many the pandemic hit home with
these images
of london emptying out just before the
first lockdown in march 2020.
how could the bustle of 44 million
visitors a year to covent garden
just vanish back then traders at jubilee
market
hoped it would be a brief shutdown
you've been here since 78
but a year on and the market's not ready
to open
because last summer they didn't have the
trade
when we did come back the market was
absolutely desolate the west end was
desolate
yeah but we were especially quiet
because we depend on tourists both
domestic and
foreign and obviously there was no
foreign tourists there's no museums to
go to there's no theaters to go
to it so there's no point in you opening
your business until
until there's a reasonable footfall over
the course of 2020
the valuation of the covent garden
estate has plunged
by a quarter the landlord has had to
restructure leases
and waive rent from struggling tenants
and only the hardiest
kept going like the florist who began
trading shrubs
to become a garden center the waldorf
and the savoy then off to opening until
the 17th of may yeah
so if there's nobody staying here and
there's certainly no
theaters i think it's going to take a
lot longer than people realized
to cover especially in uh central news
look at the streets here it's
empty the only people walking around
unbelievably are traffic wardens where
there's no cars
and there's no people this is a place
where time has stood still where
livelihoods have been put on hold but
now you can just start to feel it
the buzz is returning london is getting
ready
to put on a show but the question is
who's coming
this place can't thrive can it really
until the airports are open
and the hotels are open and the theaters
are open i think it's a really good
point you do need a lot of things to
work together
i think we have to remember that you
know somewhere like covent garden
it's both for the international tourists
but it's also for the londoner it's for
the domestic audience
it's a slow phased uncertain coming back
to life
on monday the piazza will have 800 seats
heaters and
umbrellas food alcohol and hopefully
lots of people jason farrell sky news